[Music]
you went wild over the Hunger Games you
went less wild over divergent now
prepared to be lively interested in
another franchise that Pender's to the
exact same demographic in the hopes that
they'll make enough money to split the
last book into two movies The Maze
Runner strap in for yet another
post-apocalyptic why a thriller starring
yet another diverse group of teenagers
rising up against the evil grownups who
gets wrong and to get another
unrealistic life-or-death scenario which
this time around is a maze filled with
robot spiders built to test the
survivors of a zombie virus that came to
earth when part of the Sun exploded huh
that sounds dumb welcome to the glade a
society of grown men actors playing
teenage boys who spend their days
farming dancing and exploring instead of
just jerking off all the time
there's newcomer Thomas the handsome and
brave protagonist and that's really all
there is to say about him Gally the
bully with resting [ __ ] Alby the
black guy who's killed off twice Chuck
the only fact we in a society of
able-bodied abercrombie and fitch models
and eventually a girl who does so little
for the plod she could be replaced by a
houseplant and it wouldn't make a damn
bit of difference
she's the lost one ever does that mean
it means she just became the most
popular kid in the glade this ain't your
average dauntless Quarter Quell prepare
for a whole new
world of ridiculous made up names for
simple English words like welcome to
blame never harm another glader
grade a weakling grievous calm blades
it's called the changing we call it the
flare this shank needs to be punished
Winston is a key for the slices I close
my pants three times before they got me
ever to guess they're still better than
abnegation and Haymitch Abernathy lose
yourself in the twisting maze of applaud
that will leave you with unanswered
questions like how does anyone know what
a griever is if they only come out at
night and no one has ever survived a
night in the maze and no one's ever
survived in life few minutes why does it
rain in the gray when the rest of planet
Earth is a scorched wasteland and why
don't any of these hormone field boys
show more interest when a girl finally
shows up and if these kids are
humanity's last hope for survival
why are the sinus trying to kill them
all off with robot spiders oh and since
when does a solar flare cause a virus
that turns you into a zombie and now
could trapping a bunch of teenage boys
in a maze possibly be the solution to
any of society's problem hello anyone so
follow along with our heroes as they
sprint to a conclusion that will leave
you more lost than lost that answers
absolutely none of the characters
questions or your own but since it's
aimed at teenagers it does let everyone
know that they're really really special
but you're very important she said we
were important
are we supposed to do now
make two or three more of these movies I
guess man I should really write a why a
trilogy starring the following why a
movie cliches a bland pale honk a
Kristen Stewart look-alike a dangerous
test or arena dead teenagers diversity
and evil government the leader of the
evil government dressed in white a vague
unexplained catastrophe the innocent
little kid whose death motivates the
protagonist one good actor slight
variations on the same outfit
spooky future animals and the love
triangle wait there wasn't a love
triangle in this Wow huge oversight The
Hunger maze
seriously that guy's eyebrows are so
distracting is he surprised confused
angry what is your face dude be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers
every bison dollar will be worth five
British pounds wipe them out all of them
I smell like Doritos don't say anything
just laugh your ass off oh I hate I hate
I hate Peter Pan I don't know how my
balls got deflated they felt fine to me